long before Oscar was born motion
pictures began painting the
ever-changing portrait of the world
around us
the silent film spoke an international
language because it didn't speak at all
then came sound at America soon realized
that for the rest of the world we were
the ones making foreign films as we head
to the 21st century we've learned that
there are really no foreign films only
films made in foreign languages
tonight they speak to us in Greek French
Hebrew Italian and Spanish to salute
them a distinguished actress who took
home an Oscar for her performance and on
the waterfront also the Tsar of our
business the distinguished president of
the Motion Picture Association of
America jack pilate and eva marie sink
we already know the lakes will go get
right on where there's a lot of cute
things to say but we're not going to
sing them start now all right
we would like to present the Foreign
Film Award and the outstanding nominees
in this category are from Greece
Epogen yeah and from France
Madame Rosa from Israel operation
thunderballs and from Italy a special
day and from Spain the obscure object of
desire and the winner is
why don't you enough yeah all right Oh
madam Rosa accepting the award on behalf
motion is rough
dating
I want to thank you all for this I want
to thank all the people who worked on
the film and above all I want to thank
madam Rosa herself
Simone Senora I thank everybody
especially the director of motion is ie
we did a really good job